all right let's do this let's jump over
to this next story
check this out just this picture gross
odds rose dude especially considering
coronavirus right now I don't think I
want to see any know a man filmed
licking a tub of ice cream we'll spend
30 days in jail and pay restitution to
Bluebell good good
rata tuition to Bluebell well the
restitution thing I get $2,000 Oh only
to the grand oh yeah but check it - so
so so let me start from the beginning it
all started with this viral clip of some
woman grabbing an ice cream licking it
and putting it back and then a bunch of
stupid people were gonna do the same
thing and so you ended up with these
some people who thought they were smart
this chick was wanted by the police
because she contaminated all of the ice
cream yeah so some other dude thinking I
know I will lick it put it back
but then buy it and then I can film the
video right yeah
so here's they put out pictures of this
of this woman saying we're looking for
her we're trying to figure out what
store this was at because we've got to
purge every single I think Walmart I
think was Walmart had to throw away
every single Blue Bell ice cream because
they don't know which one it is they
don't know which store they don't know
which freezer which kind of ice cream
all gone so they just purged everything
that's the law so check us out some
other guy not this guy's a different guy
films himself in a store grabbing the
ice cream opening it licking it and then
putting it back and laughing but then he
walks back to the freezer took the ice
cream back out and then he left and then
paid for it thinking it was all okay
nope you know why because the video
shows him licking and putting a back
panic so people would not buy the
product thinking it contaminated the
product they don't know where it is
exactly so I think I came over what
happened to that guy but was a similar
thing where play stupid games win stupid
prizes but people kept doing it one dude
I think I get trouble for saying this
person's that dude so I'm not gonna
explain who this person is cuz I don't
know how youtube's worked is a feminine
guy with long hair no no some person
grabbed a wasn't mouthwash we didn't
spit it back and put it back and they
try and go it was a joke we took it and
bought it later and it's like dude no
one knows that
so now the store has to come in and
throw it all away right otherwise for
one I'm not gonna buy it she's no way if
you're if we know where you're at
basically because this woman I can't
member where she was but they'd a
general idea was in Texas somewhere I
think then the people in that area are
gonna be like I'm not behind an ice
cream so the company has no choice but
to calm people down purge everything
yeah so this guy's going to jail let's
read this
CNN reports licking open containers of
Blue Bell ice cream and sticking them
back on freezer shelves was a fleeting
fad in the summer of 2019 that delighted
viral Fame chasers and enraged law
enforcement had enraged a lot more than
law enforcement dude is so gross one of
the liquors who got caught will serve
jail time and pay over $2,000 in fines
and restitution good man look there
there there I'm a very Liberty minded
person criminal mischief
sorry good I think we need criminal
justice reform like serious criminal
justice reform I think it's ridiculous
that we give people years in prison for
like nonviolent offenses and stuff like
this like this he's getting 30 days
that's a slap on the wrist but I think
that's enough time to tell these stupid
kids who do stupid things on the
internet don't do stupid things on the
internet yeah it's not so much about
making an example of them I think 30
days in jail can be severe I do think
it's important to make sure his life
won't be destroyed you won't lose his
job whatever he might circumstance it
might be but I hope this will be
something people see and be like listen
so you you hope an example is made I
said no and now I know but then you're
saying because I don't think this is an
example right I mean what I hope I hope
other people look at this and go hmm I
don't want that to happen to me I'm not
going to do this stupid thing
so the colloquial explanation of an
example being made is an overly harsh
penalty on someone to scare other people
okay this is not overly harsh okay in
that in that way I write it so people
are gonna see that you will face
repercussions so - literally it's an
example yeah yeah but I want I'll
clarify what I mean you have a judge say
like I'm giving you the maximum sentence
for disorderly conduct to make an
example out of you yeah okay and it's
like no no no that's that's not okay no
I agree that utilitarian yeah that's not
okay so he will he will also pay a fine
of $1,000 and restitution of 1,000
565 to Blue Bell creameries the
Jefferson County District Attorney's
Office said in a statement anderson
filmed himself licking the ice cream in
august more than one month after a clip
of a juvenile doing the same thing
racked up millions of views the 24 year
old told CNN affiliate he only did it to
go viral yeah well now you can do to go
to jail
but the Jefferson Jefferson County
District Attorney's Office said the act
was much more than a stunt he's just a
copycat digit attorney Bob worth minute
told WOAI in January and the way to stop
copycats is to enforce it very strongly
boom it's not about making an example of
them with a harsh penalty it's about
just saying we don't give anyone special
treatment yep so it is well we will not
tolerate this Anderson Lake good right
Anderson later claimed he bought the ice
cream after licking it and putting it
back in the freezer but the court said
his act was costly to the creamery
company which replaced its inventory
after spotting the video a month after
they to do it that one woman does it
they have to wipe it purge the entire
inventory then this guy does it man they
lost more than a thousand bucks I'd have
to imagine how definitely millions
probably so what what I feel bad for
Bluebell because they had like a
listeria outbreak what store what I
remember going into the store and I was
like mom look at all these empty shelves
this is where the Bluebell used to be
because they had a problem at one of
their factories honey it was a while ago
maybe two years ago so they pulled
everything off for that and then they
started just licking being this last
Sunday I was like wait why don't why
don't they change the way what a run why
don't you change the way they pack their
ice cream so why people are doing
Bluebell right because they don't have
the plastic on top there's no plastic in
the middle there's no seal on the
outside it's because they I I was
reading I think that it's loaded from
the top or whatever like anyt vacuum
seals so when you know you pull off the
ice cream it's like really hard it's
like it's vacuum frozen shut yeah but
but then kit you know these guys on a
kid oh yeah look at this guy this is the
picture of the guy who licked it and
then bought it and he got in trouble
Bluebell didn't respond to CNN's request
for comment but after the first viral
incident in June the Texas Creamery
condemned the act and said had removed
all half gallons of ice cream flavors
seen in elect video food tampering is on
a joke we will not tolerate
tampering with our products the company
said the teenager thought to kick off
the trend was not charged as an adult
for licking the dessert but a 36 year
old Louisiana man was arrested in July
for doing the same thing police
investigating that incident said they
believed he'd wanted to create some
notoriety for himself by posting the
footage on Facebook see these people
think I'll figure out a clever way to
commit a crime on camera but it's not
really a crime because I'm buying it but
the crime itself was creating you know
was tampering the product and putting it
back period yeah
criminal mischief is what they call it
and there's no sense but it's acting I
think that guy got charged with
basically committing a crime on camera
you trying to use it it's basically a
law that was designed to stop people I'm
trying to glorify their the actions like
filming themselves doing something they
like yo I'm so tough so this is just
another in a long line of dumb dangerous
challenges and this is a story from
earlier this month the dumb dangerous
challenges tick-tock has spawned so far
this year now of course we talked about
skull breaker challenge stupid band
they'll ban you if you do it oh good but
here's the thing tick-tock is Chinese
I'm pretty sure it's Chinese right it is
yeah but though been people now they
will dude they were banning fat weren't
they banning fatty
there were shadow banning fat people
seriously yeah you know why no I said
they said this is amazing this is
amazing you're gonna love it brilliant
because fat people get bullied they
realized the easiest way to stop the
bullying was not to ban every person who
bullies but to ban the person being
bullied Wow
it's it there it's not wrong it's not
wrong it was so you have all these
activists being like we demand you ban
hate speech and all this stuff and the
Chinese people looking at logically
we're like why ban a thousand people
will lose money ban the one person and
then they'll be known to bully and
they've started doing it gotta love you
gotta love the cold authoritarian
approach to dealing with these problems
because as much it's not the right
outcome it works bullying stops that is
utilitarian totally it's eat but but
from up from from a business point of
view they're probably thinking now we
got to ban thousands of people if we do
this yeah we're gonna our user base is
gonna shrink just man we can't just
the fat people and they did how insane
right so they're these challenges they
happen all the time so so right now they
finally banned skull breaker for those
that aren't familiar you can see these
kids basically two people will try and
convince their friend to jump with them
at the same time but as soon as the
person in the middle jumps they kick out
their legs so they fall back and hit
their head on the ground it's literally
called skull breaker they're trying to
kill you they're trying to kill you you
crazy I know this people are trying to
come up with new challenges you know so
they're like oh what could we do throw
will be the new thing so but wait wait
you got to send their stupid all of them
are stupid I just kind of like when we
talked about it oh man you're stupid
sure check us out you know actually I
don't
school breakdance to that scope breaker
is banned you're this one good what if I
told you that people are trying to jam
metal into electrical sockets the penny
challenge put a penny in it are you
kidding me also known as the outlet
challenge seriously if you do this you
you have something wrong with you and
Handy's I hate these terrible puns they
always throw it this endeavor is
literally shocking like oh my gosh what
is that beyond moronic and pathetic it
involves slipping a penny between a
partly dislodged phone charger in the
wall outlet and watching the sparks fly
last month pranks was at a Massachusetts
school gave it a whirl leading the local
fire official to observe that quote a
fire could be undetected and burning in
the wall yeah they're so not electric
lines run through via all of the walls
yeah every building so if you start an
electrical fire you you might not see it
Mandy's oh look at this the students
face various charges and possible
punishment possible now this one I think
is just stupid but I'm not super worried
about it you basically pour cereal in
someone's mouth and then milk and then
eat the cereal out of their mouth but
pretty gross like it is pretty gross
well you could choke
it's kind of it's kinda stupid you're
like giggling laughs remember we're both
flanking goes in your lungs it sounds
like a bad idea
those are fruity pebbles those are tiny
oh yeah aspirate that yeah
remember the flanking yeah it used to be
so simple he used to say guys watch me
lay on the floor and make my arms and
legs straight yeah take a picture of me
posted on reddit then somebody was like
how about I go on top of the counter and
do it and then someone else like did it
on the top of the bookshelf somebody did
on their garage yeah
and eventually started getting weird
yeah and then all sudden you have people
like on a lamppost and you're like what
is going on everyone's constant right
desperate to be the next person to
complete I want the most Fame well so
but listen listen look if all you're
gonna do is like go on a railing and lay
down okay it's not a good idea you might
fall but you're laying on a railing I'm
not gonna cry about it like I people
like I scape what I jump off buildings
you know I mean like we I know what I'm
doing maybe these people are being dumb
but from planking and the escalation of
danger this is where we go you know now
they're pouring cereal in someone's
mouth or put one remember that I told
you a story about the kid who was joking
jokingly gonna eat a tide pod yeah oh
yeah he put in his mouth not really
intending to eat it but his saliva broke
the seal yeah it got on his tongue
burned down anyway and inhaled it I mean
hailed a bunch into his lungs it started
burning his lungs and he couldn't what
do you do what detergent is corrosive
yeah and so now he's got scarred lung
tissue thought his chest his lung
capacities drop yeah no more sports
Jimmy wheezing spine team an oxygen tank
play stupid games win stupid prize let
me tell you guys a story that's a good
here's the story I was saving oh yeah I
was about to remind you I could probably
look this up because I remember I was a
long time ago there's there was a
challenge that college kids would do
where you mix all of the condiments
together with like ROM or some kind of
alcohol and shoot it and some young
20-something year old sorority girl they
mixed hot sauce soy sauce red peppers
for watch or whatever and poke vodka in
it and she giggled and took a shot of it
and the mixture caused her entire face
to swell up permanently were eyes were
stuck it was like a complete it was it
was like she was stung by a bee right
when you see people swell up yeah her
face was all puffy and bulged her eyes
were like squinted shut and they they
said that
was almost entirely permanent Wow yep
play stupid games win stupid prizes you
want to know what one of the first
things you learn in skateboarding is
when you're trying a skateboarding trick
that's difficult and you're focused yeah
you don't get hurt I mean sometimes you
do it happens let's be real but when
you're like I mean I didn't prove that
it happened of course it does like I
broke my hand someone else someone hit
me that's not fair but but you know you
get hurt I've sprained my my ankles I've
rolled my ankles so you're looking at a
stair set and this happened to me I was
trying to do a kickflip late heel flip
okay for those that understand what I'm
saying and I've done it before
and I've seen him Linda and I rolled my
ankle yeah it happens but for the most
part I've gone you know it's it's like I
don't know once or twice a year maybe
you you're focusing what you're doing
but everybody learns this lesson when
you're goofing off doing stupid things
not paying attention and you just be
very slow you won't get hurt hit a rock
boom
break your wrist so III there's a story
I tell people I was skateboarding at a
park when I was like 16 and there was a
ramp that went up about five feet
straight Bank and then went flat and
then there was a gap to the ground and
try to explain this in a way people
don't skate my understand so basically
from the top of it to the floor there
was a distance of about I think maybe
like seven feet before there was actual
ground you could write on again oh wow
that's a pretty long gap yeah seven feet
not really
that's pretty longer from [ __ ] you know
so what you know anyway the goal is to
jump from the top over this part you
can't skate on and land back on the on
the ground right so I tried maybe 30
times to do what's called a backside 180
and this is when you jump and spin 180
degrees but you can't see in front of
you right you're looking down basically
blind side mm-hmm I fell 30 times with
slide would Rahl would get up and try
again and finally land it and I'm like
yeah and I'm all proud of myself
literally a minute after I land it and
I'm riding back around the park a little
kid look was with it with his mom runs
right past trips on the the outlet where
the gap was falls down breaks his wrist
Wow it's always when you're goofing off
mm-hmm play stupid games you win stupid
prizes man you know I think what we're
seeing now with with like tick tock
in YouTube in these stupid viral
challenges I gotta be honest I think
before social media people were still
doing this dumb stuff we're just now
watching him do it
hmm I think there's definitely an
escalation because people oh no for sure
every single person every single story
we're reading about the guy jumping up
on the plane I've got coronavirus hail
coffin every single one of them said I
just wanted to be famous I just wanted I
wanted to go viral that's everybody's
reasoning for being this stupid no no
there was stupid to begin
yeah yes yes correlations right but
still you know they were probably doing
stupid things but then once this
happened they're like oh I'm gonna
one-up all the stuff that I know because
this is all what everybody knows so I
have to one-up it yeah the the the story
we cover the other day was the kids who
got charged with like third-degree
aggravated assault yeah breaker I mean
that's that's I don't know how much time
they're gonna get but you're right
they'll probably again or something yeah
they're I mean I don't know if it's
these kids here but it's literally
called skull breaker yeah you think you
think people would not want to break
their friends skulls air-quote friends
right yeah someone ever did that to me
cut from my life my yeah yeah see I'm
making pizza right now but you you don't
get it you I you don't you try to crack
my skull open yeah that's good reason
not to give you my pizza you know what
get out of my house why are you still
here thanks for checking out this
segment from the Tim cast IRL podcast we
do the show every Monday through Friday
at 8 p.m. sometimes an hour or two and
we do have a full live recorded version
of the show that includes a lot of
comments and smaller segments you
probably don't see if you want to check
that out you can watch live at 8 p.m.
Monday through Friday or become a member
of this channel and for five bucks a
month you get full access to all of the
recorded podcasts every day after the
show we make them available in the
community section of this YouTube
channel so don't forget to subscribe and
stick around for more segments and more
shows Monday through Friday at 8 p.m.
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all in the next show
you